today i'm going to be speaking with joe
henrich who's professor of human
evolutionary biology at harvard
university and also author of the book
the weirdest people in the world how the
west became psychologically peculiar and
particularly prosperous it's really
great having you on today i appreciate
your time
yeah good to be with you
so let's first talk about weird is an
acronym w-e-i-r-d
for western educated industrialized rich
and democratic so
how did you first start to sort of uh
think about this this group of people as
a group of people and sort of what the
defining characteristics are
yeah so uh around 2006 or so i began
working with two cultural psychologists
steve heinen arnorn zion at the
university of british columbia and you
know we had come together over lunch and
stuff and began to talk about our
research and what we each had realized
somewhat independently was not only was
there a cultural variation around the
world and
key aspects of psychology but that the
populations most commonly studied by
psychologists and others were unusual
when seated in that global perspective
so they were often at the tail end of
the distribution or you know
distinctively set apart from other
populations
so we came up with the idea of writing a
paper together the weirdest people in
the world meant to raise an alarm kind
of a methodological
methodological concern
aimed at psychologists and others
that they were over generalizing from
the populations that they studied that
they they couldn't make assumptions
about human behavior by studying
american undergraduates or people online
people from those sources and then as a
way of referring to the populations most
commonly studied by researchers we came
up with the acronym weird
just as a way and it's meant as a
consciousness raising device to kind of
remind researchers that they they should
be cautious about generalizing
so when we talk about the
characteristics
western
makes sense educated makes sense
industrialized
rich and democratic when we talk about
rich are we talking about rich at a
global scale or are we saying even
within these western countries we're
talking about the rich
well i mean what we had in mind was uh
mostly psychologists were sampling
undergrad at the time they were mostly
sampling undergraduates from a small
handful of countries so the u.s canada
a couple places in in europe australia
places like that so you know to the
degree to which american undergraduates
tend to be disproportionately sampled
from the middle and upper class yeah so
in that case it leaves out
um
lower ses and then of course globally
those are among the richest countries in
the world
before we move on to some of the other
aspects of your research it's often
repeated and things that are often
repeated aren't necessarily true but
it's often repeated that
um
if you compare folks from the large
cities in the united states
to the rest of the u.s and then compare
them to people from places like london
and paris etc that the folks from large
cities across these countries are much
more similar than those within the
united states living living in urban
versus rural settings for example
do you think in your research does that
sound right to you or does that maybe
miss some important things
well definitely misses some important
things so uh in in putting together the
evidence that you know we were able to
gather you can compare
uh you know corporate managers or
executives from around the world working
all working at you know leading uh
productive companies and you can detect
the same kind of psychological variation
you can get if you compare you know the
the
groups from lower socioeconomic status
or you know more representative
populations of these countries can you
talk a little bit about you know in in
the title of the book
you use the term psychologically
peculiar peculiar can just mean unique
and different but it can also mean that
the sort of something maybe that we
would identify as strange or unusual
what are the psychological peculiarities
of of this group that is often the
source for for studies
yeah so the key thing i wanted to focus
on was trying to understand the
psychological variation we find around
across populations around the globe so
some of the key dimensions that emerged
were one
is a kind of psychological cluster or
complex called individualism
that's associated with how people think
about themselves about overconfidence
and self-esteem
and the role of guilt versus shame
and so there's a whole cluster there
where
uh people in weird societies tend to
think about themselves as uh
unitary individual decision makers
rather than nodes in a social network
they tend to be overconfident they tend
to have concerns about guilt but shame
is relatively unimportant
this goes along with another pattern
which is analytic versus holistic
thinking
so there's tends to be an inclination
towards more analytic thinking so
breaking problems down into parts
assigning properties to those parts and
then reasoning from that point of view
as opposed to looking at the
relationships among parts um to to make
explanations so we find lots of
variation there
uh the use of intentionality and moral
judgments to be another one so lots of
westerners really think intentions are
important but in other places you know
intentions don't seem to be important at
all at least in making some moral
judgments
um
moral universalism so the degree to
which you think everyone should be
judged by the same moral standards
versus moral particularism where you
make a difference between
how people within some circle
uh should be judged versus people
outside that circle trust in strangers
as another important one things like
that
what are the sources of these
peculiarities i mean is it is it media
is it the characteristics themselves
like being you know rich or
industrialized or whatever the case may
be
does religion and and or churches
play a role what what what causes this
well i mean there's probably lots of
factors that affect
overall global psychological variation
but in the book i was particularly
interested in trying to understand why
it was that european and european
descent populations became particularly
individualistic
and particularly
have a strong impersonal pro-sociality
so this trust in cooperation with
strangers which should be contrasted
with a more interpersonal pro-sociality
where people are are much more
cooperative and positively inclined
towards people they know people they
have relationships with that kind of
thing within group loyalty
so um
the the case that i make is that much of
the kind of unusual nature of european
society as it emerged in the last 500
years
comes from
uh a
particular set of taboos and
prescriptions that one branch of
christianity the one that evolves into
the roman catholic church began to
promulgate in late antiquity and
eventually
although gradually spreads throughout
many parts of western europe and
transforms the intensive complex kinship
organizations that you would find in
many pre-christian european societies
and breaks them down into monogamous
nuclear
families
and then this opens the door for other
kinds of institutions impersonal
institutions eventually things like
democracy and western law and whatnot
but initially things like guilds
universities monasteries
that were organized differently and
built around notions of individuals
trying to attract individuals so it
really puts these populations on a
different kind of cultural evolutionary
trajectory than we've we see in many
societies around the world and back in
history so in in if i understand
correctly even though today
in the united states for example
roman catholics are not a majority
the
evolution and growth of the roman
catholic church starting 500 years ago
in europe
led to in a sense psychological changes
which include acceptance of certain
types of relationships to institutions
that are still very relevant today in
terms of how this group you study
relates to the world
that's right you should think of that
the stuff the catholic church did as
initiating a kind of cultural
evolutionary process and then
these principles get to varying degrees
embedded in secular institutions and
become part of the general cultural
milieu
one of the one of the cases i make in
the book is that this process led to the
emergence of protestantism so you know
there's this goes on for a thousand
years before martin luther and others um
initiate this protestant reformation
which of course is a is a constellation
a mosaic of different religious
movements that are rebelling against the
catholic church but i mean they have
sort of super weird characteristics in
the sense that they're really focused on
mental states the role of intentionality
centrality on the individual emphasis on
hard work deferral of gratification
uh
so
it is only further accentuate some of
the basic
characteristics that had been developing
prior to that you know some of the
characteristics you write about and that
you've spoken about high level of
individualism
um
maybe
analytical to some degree in a way
that's not as common in other societies
or in other parts of society
non-conformism etc i will often hear
from people when they visit a country
that
is outside of of this group you know
friends who have done work in southeast
asia or have gone to africa etc and they
seem to very quickly pick up on the fact
that there's just sort of like something
different about
the perspective on the world around them
that has to do with
uh some of the traits that you're
pointing out here so it seems as though
part of the reason many who are part of
this weird group aren't aware of this is
they're just around people like
themselves all the time in other words
we have the ability to notice when folks
are different we maybe just aren't
spending enough time around them but
that once you do you realize that there
is there is some kind of cultural
difference here yeah absolutely so i
mean that's the real value to
to traveling and living in other
societies so you know uh i come up as an
anthropologist so as a cultural
anthropologist i i got to live in
amazonia in small communities i did a
long stretch of field work in the south
pacific on remote islands and you know
really tried to dig in and live among
the people and to the degree to which
other people did that for other reasons
it really does kind of you know it's
like a fish out of water or something
you really then begin to notice that
lack of water around you or the
striking difference that you don't see
unless
unless you get removed from the water
is it hard to understand some of these
things just by being told about them
because what my mind is going to is if
you read some of jared diamond's books
for example where he talks extensively
about his time spent in the pacific with
the maori people etc
when you just read his descriptions of
the culture yes it's different but i can
only imagine that the degree to which
you can really feel that partially has
to be from actually being there
thousands of miles from where you
normally are and sort of being told
about this phenomena can only really do
so much
yeah i mean uh
there's different ways to get at it so
of course you know living with people
and learning the language and trying to
really engage in the society is the is
the best way to get a feel for it yeah i
mean there are you know
i guess not you know things like novels
can try to bring you and put you in the
shoes of someone living in that society
you know an honor society where you're
very concerned about uh maintaining your
honor because that protects your family
and it's core to your identity as a
person
um so so that's another way and then of
course
you know some amount of travel can at
least give you a feel for it
are any of the distinctions that you
study
can can value judgments be assigned to
them to some degree in terms of either
what's quote better for the individuals
within or for
the groups and societies at a whole or
or is this merely we're observing
differences and that's as far as it goes
well so my mission in the book was just
to
well to kind of start out by documenting
the differences but the thing i was
really interested in doing is explaining
the variation and cueing to my readers
many of which i sort of assumed as i as
i wrote the book would be mostly weird
so i was trying to jar them
in ways that would make them recognize
the water so to speak so recognize the
sort of psychological differences so
when i talk about analytic thinking you
know analytic thinking can be very
powerful breaking things down into parts
and assigning them properties it's
really the basis of how you know what
physics is right break everything down
into particles and give them charges or
uh spin or charge or something like that
and then explain everything from that
psychologists give peace people
personalities and try to explain that
economists do a similar thing so it's
very powerful but you can miss the
forest so like some of the subsections
in the book are like missing the forest
reminding people that if you're too much
of an analytic thinker um
you can miss how all the parts fit
together and how the relationships are
so important
so for example when you do when
psychologists do work on what leads to
effective problem solving in teams the
best teams at solving problems and
engaging in creativity are teams that
have a mixture of analytic and holistic
thinkers so you need both uh growth
groups towards the end of the book i
really emphasize the role of uh
embracing cultural differences for
generating innovation so most most
innovations are
recombinations of existing ideas and so
the degree to which you can get people
with very different ideas different ways
of seeing the world to interact in
mutually trusting and potentially
cooperative and beneficial ways you're
just going to generate more innovation
um so one of the things i've been
researching lately is the is the degree
to which immigration energized
economic growth and innovation patenting
within the united states
you talk um in the book about delayed
gratification and differences um uh
among different societies on delayed
gratification many of us have probably
heard of these studies that were done on
little kids where you know they say well
i'm gonna put a cookie in front of you
and i'm gonna leave and if you don't eat
it i'll give you a second cookie later
and you kind of evaluate you know who
does what um
i think to some degree
in weird societies as as defined by you
being able to delay gratification is
seen as objectively good
and that may not always be the case but
it seems as though it's seen as sort of
like a virtue in some sense being able
to delay gratification and one of the
things you find is that
not delaying gratification is more
common among non-weird people
is that a place where there's actually
sort of like logical explanations for
why it's not objectively better to delay
gratification if you consider the
context maybe
yeah so uh that's a great case because
there people do have a sense that that's
sort of a virtue that's very much a
protestant virtue actually
so you get that right out of
protestantism um
so the way to think about it is that
these aspects of our psychology are
adapted to the institutional and
ecological environments that we have to
confront
so uh they did chris blattman and
colleagues uh
political scientists and economists the
university of chicago uh did this
research in liberia where they they
basically created a training course to
try to increase the self-regulation of
poor men to try to make them more
patient and more willing to defer
gratification
uh the training worked and they were
able to show that on the psychological
tests men were willing to defer
gratification more and initially this
seemed to be a big success because the
men were able to begin to develop little
nest eggs of savings and things like
that right okay so that's working but
then it turns out that because the
environment is so unstable the men would
get robbed or they'd get shaken down by
the police or something would happen and
they'd lose their complete nest egg so
they wouldn't get the pleasure that
would have come from
indulging in that
so that that's one way and you need to a
stable environment where you can
preserve that savings and you need the
chance that you're going to be alive
when you get a chance to take advantage
of it otherwise it's better to to
consume now when you're sure you're
going to get something out of it the
other thing that that varies across
societies is in a lot of cases
if i accumulate much my my relatives are
going to come and ask for it essentially
so we'll die there'll be a funeral or
there'll be a wedding um so what i do
one way to deal with a any kind of
rising surplus is just to give it away
have a party or give it to others and
the way people think about that or maybe
not consciously but the way it ends up
functioning is that you're storing your
surplus in the good will and
relationships you have with others right
when you're in need you don't have to
have a nest egg your nest egg is
scattered amongst all these
friends and relatives in close contacts
that you've cultivated over long periods
of time yeah that's super interesting
and to some degree i've studied that a
little bit in hasidic jewish communities
uh and there's a there that that
phenomena is very very notable there
interestingly enough
the book is fascinating it's called the
weirdest people in the world how the
west became psychologically peculiar and
particularly prosperous we've been
speaking with the book's author harvard
university professor joe henrich joe
really appreciate your time today
okay well it's great to be with you